[Musique]
le port de Marseille comme d'autres
grands ports notamment Dunkerque sont
vraiment des lieux où la transition
énergétique se met en oeuvre de façon
très concrète ça pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que
on est sur des endroits où on a des
industries les plus polluantes la
sidérurgie la pétrochimie et puis on est
un endroit où il y a également des modes
de transport lourd qui aussi font partie
des des polluants les plus les plus
importants et donc ils sont très engagés
sur cette question de la transition
énergétique dans notre mission on fait
beaucoup de dictions mais on a des
informations macro en allant sur le
terrain on a été dans le département du
Rhône dans la chimie et là on vient dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône on rencontre le
terrain et on va avoir des informations
micro et je prends un exemple la volonté
du port de Marseille c'est de faire que
les bateaux hackaient soit électrifiés
d'une façon très pratique la quantité
d'électricité elle correspond à la
production pratiquement trois EPR donc
ça c'est les choses qu'on n'aurait pas
dans un vision déjà sur le terrain
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est macgm Emers sont les
deux transporteurs maritimes qui ont
lancé les premiers des ambitions fortes
et des ambitions qui se sont traduits
par des actes concrets c'est un chemin
compliqué c'est un chemin qui va
nécessiter des investissements en
matière de recherche en matière
scientifique il va falloir financer ces
nouvelles ces nouvelles technologies ces
nouvelles énergies on aura évidemment
besoin du soutien réglementaire du
soutien législatif du soutien aussi
des pouvoirs publics si on veut aller
vite
[Musique]